what's up what's up you little knuckle
huffers
how you guys doing out there out there
probably been sniffing your daddy's
gasket i know it
and you've been out there crumbing
around on your grandmother's freaking
skirt
praise god baby good to be here with you
i am um what am i doing i
am well i tell you a damn branch fell in
my yard
a damn branch man uh
you know you know one of mother nature's
damn knuckles bro that [ __ ] just fell
in my yard man it just um
i mean a branch is basically it's like a
tree just taking a [ __ ] in your yard
let's be honest you know and so that
thing hit you know it hit down in the
yard and the man came
and uh you know the branch man up there
from richard's branch company or
something
richard's forest or d forestry or
something i don't know what they were
doing some kind of
i mean it's probably you know people
using drugs and trying to get better and
but working with branches in the
meantime and stuff but um
the man came and he said eleven hundred
dollars
to get the branch out of the yard
and that shook me a little
you know that really twisted my dick man
honestly
you know it felt like somebody just
wrapped my nuts around my dick
because 1100 that's all you know dude i
had a felony mold building
offered to kill someone that we both
knew that we didn't
you know i guess think
should be alive he offered to kill him
for a thousand so you telling me richard
that i can get a bra a man a human
removed from the earth for a thousand
but eleven hundred out here on this dead
wood
[Music]
so i'll tell you what i did i'll tell
you like what i did i got me a fiskars
saw
i brought it
i got me that fiskars 18 inch right
there
with that antelope front
you know that anteater that gripper baby
and as he's telling me
as he's telling me eleven i'm cutting
that bastard off and throwing chunks
over the fence
there goes two hundred dollars worth
right there now we down to 900
richards
and he's still rattling on about the
price and then she had said we gotta
have our guys insured
i said [ __ ] put on some cleats you know
what i'm saying protect your ankles
daddy
and i sawed off another chunk and threw
that bastard over the fence
now two-fifths of it's gone richards
we're down a damn uh
seven eight hundred dollars worth of
branch left according to you
so you just gotta be careful though gal
jam
they will gouge ya
here we go robert randolph and the
family
band
baptized me
[Music]
dirty
i'm
dip me in the water baby
[Music]
what else
he baptized me baby boy
and there you go with the awkward fade
out per usual
and you know that that's how i do that
oh i'm begging you please baptize me and
that's
robert randolph and the family band
i mean i remember seeing him
at a hotel somewhere and
was it atlanta maybe or
somewhere i just remember seeing him at
a at a hotel
and man i was just fired up
i saw him in the lobby he wouldn't
remember this is a decade ago
you know back when i was young and my
chunk was thick back then
and my body was strong
but baptize me that's what they say
dipped me in the water
take me to the real wow
but
and we back from easter you know i'm
saying all these eggs have been hunted
and it's spring time is in the air
and you'll see it a lot of lady be
flashing that that bottom
trying to get sprayed in trying to get
um
affection
and it's that time of year it's it's
interesting that mother nature built in
a time
where the spunk starts to fly baby you
know it
where the titties starts to perk
mother nature built that time into the
clock
it's pretty fascinating but happy
belated easter everyone
you know jesus is back hide and go seek
that i'll tell you this
hide and go seek champion brother
yes christo you know what i'm saying
that mexican-american bad boy jesus
christ
i mean the fact that they couldn't find
him for a couple days he's dead he's not
dead he's back he's ghosting
and now all these [ __ ] want him to be
honest with you praise god
um i hope you had a nice easter man i
went to
louisiana spent time with my family
uh what did we do we had we had some
you know we did a crawfish boil down
there
and you know the crawfish boil everybody
comes out people come out whether
they've been
hiding for the winter whatever you know
your cousin little andrew come out he
got a new mole on his face
say he's talking to a girl or something
he ain't talking to no girl everybody
knows that [ __ ]
you know your friend come out he's
handicapped your brother buddy come out
he was in a fire
maybe big tiffany was in a uh in a fire
she got burnt out
you know and she got some sav on her
back or something
but but yeah happy easter man uh
baptize me
that's what he's saying robert randolph
put me in the water
you know it's fascinating about
baptizing it's just getting that wash
you know that's the
that's the freaking lord's car wash
right there
and they dip you through that plane of
water and air
it's really fascinating because you
could take a fish in one hand
and you could take a bird an air bird in
the other
and you could switch them at the same
time put one under water one out of the
water
and they both can't handle they can't
handle less smoke baby on the lungs
it's just interesting what a what a what
a line of pressure
what a what a horizon of existence that
plane is between water and air
it's pretty fascinating
and we used to be in water when you're
born when you're an infantile
a baby you're in your mother's body you
in there about you
you backstroking in that vag gravy dog
you bet you
backstroking
in the lord's butternut squash baby you
bet you know what i'm saying you're in
there
you in that hot tub baby up in the
ovaries
you hot tubbing
and you breathing water you're breathing
liquid let me look it up to make sure
cause i'm
i don't want to lie to you do we
breathe liquid when we are baby
uh do we breathe liquor baby the
mother's placenta helps the baby
breathe while it is growing in the womb
oxygen and carbon dioxide flow through
the blood
in the placenta most of it goes to the
heart and flows through the
baby's body at birth the baby's lungs
are filled with fluid
it's just pretty it's just wild how that
baptism that dip
they're really they're almost taking you
back to whenever you were made when you
were
you know before you were after market
before the devil got to you and before
you were after market
and before you got you know when they
when they baptized you they're almost
just dipping you in that water
just saying hey remember this remember
when the lord had you all
fished out when you was gilled out
it's interesting man i think it's
interesting what the hell do i know
um but you had a good time man i slept
in a child's bed
you know with no child in there because
you know i'm
i'm happy to not be a pedophile or to be
um
doing anything like that
and i want to thank god right now that
i'm not a pedophile man because
it just seems unrewarding
it seems
it just seems like there's no
you know it's the one sport you can't
really tell anybody you play
if you do it and it's uh i miss the
devil's backgammon and i'm glad i'm not
doing it today
or ever ever also i want to say that i
want to say ever
as well and i'm going to say it loud um
what else is going on
um oh i'm in a new studio anything about
that here i am
we've got a new fake plant
dude i'll tell you this a fake plant
costs 119 dollars
for this [ __ ] front yard toupee right
here baby boy
dollars for this [ __ ] chlorophyll
skin graft dog
119 dollars
for this fern baby to fit this [ __ ]
now fascinating that's the market we
need to be in the fake plant market
you know when i was young we grew up
next to um
a place where they was doing uh
what is it called not projectiles but um
uh
what's it called when you need something
to reach something um
but you don't have it something happened
fire hatchet
you know accident something like a
prosthetic
we grew up na over near a prosthetic
place and sometimes we'd go in there
after hours and the men would be in
there and they would hold it and uh
they'd get you a beer or something if
you wanted
if you was of age they would you know
they kind of had the
arm and the leg kind of where you could
drink you know use it to have some beer
for the adults but
yeah and early prosthetics man them
[ __ ] was really
uh it was bottom shelf you know some
were rubber i remember
um someone had like a little thing you
could pot a cigarette or something just
like [ __ ] that was kind of vague you
know
uh but we grew up not far from a place
that did that
um what was i talking about i don't even
know
but yeah i got that fisker 18 inch blade
and that's what i use to solve my
problem right now
in my own yard
but yeah being a homeowner is really
jarring
you know i'm out here in the central
east and i got a locale now and
it is it's just like every time i
leave it's like ah do i leave the lights
on what's on
is the oven on is the garbage disposal
on is the um
porch light on is the back porch light
on
you know there's just so many little
things to think about
and before i never had a i would leave
the house with everything on garbage
disposal
lights uh thermostat
um everything [ __ ] cut it all
on you know let this [ __ ] vibrate while
i'm out let it shake a little
but now it's like everything's just like
okay
i guess everything's fine so it's just a
tricky time man
uh i want to uh thank uh liquid death
for supporting us
they're a beautiful supporter
and it's good water if you like canned
water from the mountains you will
enjoy it and if you want to die die wet
i say that's the only way to do it i was
thinking about water and
ah and that song had me thinking about
it that baptized me by robert randolph
had me really thinking about that water
that agua baby that spanish water
and uh i got some shades right here i
threw these bastards back on
you know i was thinking that
you know water was one of god's apps
originally
you know people are shocked that god god
have some good apps when you think about
it
water fire gravity
um smoke wolves
what else maybe
lightning maybe i guess i mean lightning
is good but
yeah lightning and
that's probably one of the some of the
top four or seven
and the thing is is that uh
those are the those are the original
apps people nowadays think oh i got this
i got
go puff i got you know big girl or
whatever some of the apps are
[ __ ] that is that's nothing cause the i
mean god had those apps baby fire
water dude he pressed that water button
atlantis dog you know what i'm saying
the bus stop was suddenly freaking 400
feet under water
you know he he he uh pressed the fire
button
and bam son san bernardino was born
you know it's just we got to think about
the power
mother nature really has the ultimate
apps even though we get caught up in our
own we start to
get further and further from nature
you know i get further and f it's kind
of remarkable because i'll see a drone
and i'll be fascinated but i'll see one
of those
fat bumblebees one of those freaking
lemony
thickets you know and i won't think i
won't
be like oh whatever you know
i'm kind of scared or i'm not scared i
can't really decide but
wasps i know i'm scared fat bumblebees
like
by the time i decide if i'm scared or
not i've kind of left wherever
it was at and they didn't have them when
i was young they didn't have those fat
bumblebees
these [ __ ] are new these bit they're
from mexico or somewhere
where you know there's been a lot of
incoming traffic you feel me
so that's a new thing man
but it's just funny that i'll see a
drone and be fascinated but i'll see a
bumblebee
and be like uh and it's like damn that
thing's working without batteries baby
boy
that's you know
that's the lord's drone right there
so that's a lot of what's going on um
what else i want to let you know that i
got a tour i'm going to do a new tour at
the end of uh
not the end but a little bit later in
this year
i don't really know what to name it yet
but i'll be thinking about it
if you have suggestions for a name as
always you can hit the hotline
985-664-9503
um also let you know that gang gang the
slides are back in stock
there's footy for those footy fashion
pieces baby
and um to be good to yourself hoodies
are back in stock as well
so a lot of nice stuff going on
uh what else let's hit a little bit of
news here bad
baby join only fans and if she's the
cash me outside girl
and she definitely you could tell she's
probably been banging a lot of brothers
and that's
let's be honest dude
you know you ain't getting near her
unless you really
that cafe de calor with a little neck
tat fam you feel me
like i bet an ankle brace it makes you
know really makes her feel erect
probably
and i can say that she's not a child
anymore also is this is this a crime
um but anyway she's on only fans now
and they said she made a ton of money on
only fans the most ever like a million
dollars let me read it actually
uh she turned 18 and made one million
dollars in six
hours pretty crazy
you know what scares me about apps is
that
just how they can quickly share whatever
information
and just the freedoms we allow them to
have
you know when i was growing up and i was
a child
if you say you bought something from
somewhere
you know you bought your little don or a
little crawler from the bakery
and they'd have a big lady working over
there look
if it wasn't if it wasn't a big lady
working at the bakery
i'm leaving okay okay boss i ain't
buying a [ __ ] donut
from some little cr you know some skinny
little biscuit
you know some little uh
purulene you know or whatever those are
called those skinny sweet sticks
p rulings and sometimes i'll be honest
somebody break out a thing of pure
orleans they probably it's a gay man
and that's factual man but in no shade
bro
but what i'm trying to say is um
the bait if
you want a fat you want a thicky thicky
thick
you know you want that
you want you know you want captain
thickeopodomus working at the bakery you
want a dude who's putting butter on his
own arm and about to [ __ ] slice it up
and eat it
you know you want that big [ __ ]
who's in there just frosting up them
front tats bro
you want somebody thick at a bakery
because you know it's going to be good
but what i'm saying is in the old days
if you walked into a bakery you bought
something
they didn't run out the back door of the
bakery and tell everybody what you
bought
there wasn't somebody running out the
back door saying oh you know theo loves
uh
chocolate rum raisin uh doughnut
holes so then now for the rest of your
life
you have some chocolate run rum rum
raisin hitman
looming around at every turn
because that's what it's like now you
get on any app you buy something
for the rest of your life they haunt you
with the [ __ ] you want asics
you want asics bruh you'll be getting
your mom a damn
casket and you'll be like damn
nothing go with that casket like some
dark ass asics
you want these wood grain asics like
[ __ ] i don't want any a6
that was years ago
but you know so you didn't have that
back in the day but
now you buy anything you have it
and so it's a little alarming to me in
the sense of an 18 year old
gets on to the sex world and is selling
sexuality selling that kind of stuff
it's not wrong
and and everybody's opinion is is valid
but what worries me is then
whoever buys it is going to be getting
baited throughout the rest of their life
with
that dirty bait that young bait
that cusp bait
that line between air and water
where you breathing and you drown him
and that's what scares me is that you
can't just make a purchase one day or
make a
honeymoon [ __ ] i might call it a mistake
if you buy and looks at looks at a
children
at an 18 year old that's a mistake
but it's a legal i mean look it's in
your loins i feel it but
at my age it's a little risque
but what i worry about then is the
algorithms the
the ability of apps to then haunt you to
chase you
to say hey about this young titty you
know
oh we got a girl she was a senior
volleyball captain
and she bout them tits now she's 18. you
know it's like
that kind of stuff because the algorithm
is going to haunt you now
whereas back in the day it was a little
different you buy something at a bakery
that everything stopped at the counter
and the only person that knew your
secret was
thick tiff back or
fat allen or whoever you know no no
shame bro no shame no shame
so anyway i don't know exactly what i'm
saying but that's the kind of stuff that
worries me is the is the ability of
these apps to keep tabs and the ability
of that
because how many times before they keep
haunting somebody with an 18 year old
18 year old and then you're just making
a pervert
i don't know i don't know anything man
so but anyway that's what's going on man
um we got a lot of great calls that came
in man some special stuff and
i want to be a part of that and
and i thank you guys for being a part of
uh of just
continuing to be a part of my life over
these years
and i'm excited to get back on tour man
and uh
we had a show in dallas the other night
just a little show and man it was fun
i went and looked at some theaters uh to
maybe shoot a netflix special over there
some beautiful places and just to be
working in a
you know in a state they're about to be
at full capacity over there and so
that's a blessing man it's exciting
and it needs to happen i think that
whatever's
in the air whatever core is out there
the disease needs to run
through us
it needs to run through us man
that's what i think what do i know i
don't know [ __ ] i mean look at me
so i'm dressed like this i'ma tell you
this man i've been losing my hair and
you know it and i do everything i can to
reposition my hair to restructure
i will recall hair
you know i'll frickin i'll stay up all
night writing notes to my mustache
trying to convince it to move up north
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time they
are 35 that's unbelievable
but not really it's pretty obvious if
you look at people
someone's doing bad with their hair but
i'm here to tell you it's okay
you know more than 50 million men in the
us suffer from male pattern baldness
it's not like something you did
you know it's just that topography
you know it's that farming
but i'm going to tell you right now
there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
and keeps offers both that's right
i take keeps because i want to keep my
hair
i tried it because i was worried about
losing my hair
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
theo to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash t-h-e-o to get your first
month
free keeps.com slash
theo prevention is key keep what you
have
treatments can take up to four to six
months to see results so act fast
keeps has more five star reviews than
any of its competitors that's right
that's right you want to keep that fluff
baby that's what you have to keep
you got to keep that fluff i'll tell you
also about mint
mobile after years of fine print
contracts and getting ripped off by
big wireless hey hey my name's
donnie sprint if we learned every
anything
it's that there's always a catch so when
i first heard that mint mobile offers
premium
wireless service starting at just 15
bucks a month 15 bucks a month
for wireless service
that's dust deal i thought what's the
catch
but after speaking with them i realized
there is not one that's right
mint mobile's secret sauce is that
they're the first company to sell
wireless service online only
by cutting out retail stores there's no
crazy overhead costs that get passed
down to you
in the form of mystery fees nope none of
that
it's all gone there's no brook and
mortar stores
mint just passes on the sweet savings
toyo
toya for people looking for extra
savings mint mobile offers premium
wireless for just 15 bucks a month
that's i just keep telling you that
because those are the facts
if you're not 100 satisfied mint mobile
has you covered with their seven
day money back guarantee
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month and
get the plan shipped to your door for
free
go to mintmobile.com t-h-e-o
that's m-i-n-t m-o-b-i-l-e dot com slash
theo
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com
theo we got a lot of great calls that
came
in what else is new going on in my life
you know uh i got a lot to do at home
man
geez gee got a lot to do brother
you know this is just
there's just so many you know
you need towels you need soaps you need
silverware
i got plastic plates and unfortunately i
got three things of plastic plates
because
the picture on the website looked like
bowls but it was plates
and i think it's said bowls i think they
spelled plates with a b-o-w-l-e-s
so i'll fold the freaking plate in like
a little bowl and get my cereal in the
morning
and then they got some red robins doing
a nest outside
with eggs in it and so i don't want to
go out there and cause any harm i don't
want to affect mother nature
i got enough [ __ ] on my [ __ ] docket
at the moment so
so that's where i am with that um
what else had some people come move
refrigerator in and they broke one of
the front steps
had the limb fall in the backyard
um you know so just regular life man
regular life [ __ ] don't have a hamper
yet so it's just
you know when you don't have a hamper
everywhere is a hamper
you know the drill boy everywhere's a
hamper
so i'm just doing that i'm living that
life right now
and i think some of it feels a little
sad
you know it's a little sad to be uh
not sad but it's like you know it makes
you it's one of those moments where you
get in a new place and you're like okay
it's it's almost like walking up a
staircase not really up but even
sideways on a on a
platform or something you and you the
the view is different
like okay well here i am now i'm in a
home
how do i feel what's it feel like you
know
[Music]
what other responsibilities do i need a
dog do i need
you know one of those freezers for like
catfish and beef and stuff that you keep
in the refrigerator in the in the uh
uh garage you know you just start
thinking what other adult [ __ ] do i need
do i need a wreath on my door at
christmas you know
it's just you start thinking about a lot
of stuff like that
um adulthood you know it's a little
scary
a little scary uh but it's good it's
just a little scary
let's get the news one more time man uh
an article justice
clarence thomas and i didn't i didn't
even know his first name was justice but
that's pretty dope justice clarence
thomas said on monday
that congress should suggest whether
laws should be updated to regulate
social media platforms
he claims social media platforms have
come to have unbridled control over
unprecedented amounts of speech
suggested the platform should be used as
common carriers such as trains and
telephone companies
both having large amounts of government
regulations
you know i think about this a lot
because it does
seem to me that
what used to be people just talking now
the the place where you talk
is now social media that has become the
the communication environment
and i guess people could debate and say
well no you could just talk to your
neighbors or talk to some
but you can but that's not really what
goes on anymore
you know most talking or communicating
is done now
online whereas it used to be
you had to go and see
something live there's now so much more
accessibility to
communication online most accessibility
to communication is online
um
and i i guess
i feel like people should be able to say
whatever they want
because it's almost like
the companies have become like the
microphone so everybody has a microphone
now and the companies have owned the
microphone
where they can't own your actual voice
but they own
the thing your voice goes through to
reach others you know
that spigot
and and yeah
it i feel like it should be regulated
somehow
you hate to have the government involved
but
at the same time because you want like
free speech but
if the way we speak is now goes through
a filter
and that filter has judgment or
jurisdiction over what is okay to say
then that seems
very dangerous
because now speech doesn't feel free it
feels very specific
like you're allowed to say things but
not these things
and i'd love to know what some of you
guys think on that you know
if you could hit the hotline
985-664-9503
um yeah you know i
i just because i feel like a lot of
things yeah they're just not allowed to
be shared and
uh not allowed to be said online things
get labeled
um things get labeled and then taken
down
so that just feels alarming at least let
people decide
what they want to hear or believe
but everyone should have the ability to
share i feel like
i feel like and i'm open to uh
to hear different people's thoughts on
that
because maybe also it's just our
responsibility
to be like oh well this platform isn't
uh
doesn't allow everything to be shared
and i think most people know that
but i don't know
just a lot there man there's a lot in
that little cauldron
so if you want to stir that thing hit
the hotline 985-664-9503
um what else do we have here we got a
call that came in from
skyler what's up theo this is uh my
name's skyler i'm out of the deep north
up here in
california humboldt county hey
scholar thank you for calling up there
from humboldt county you know my friend
went to school up there and he actually
died but
uh beautiful fella and his uh birth date
has passed my friend ryan thomas and
i hope he knows that i love him in
heaven baby uh gang baby onward
uh thank you for calling brother uh
i had a question for you my girlfriend
she's
we've been going on three years now just
about and she's
got this opportunity to do 80 days
backpacking food kayaking out in new
zealand
uh just been kind of thinking about it a
lot it's kind of a long time away
uh just wondering what's your thoughts
on how i can handle that
and yeah man i love your podcast looking
through it every day
doing drywall and painting and you get
me through that [ __ ] so
appreciate you thank you a lot later
gang brother yen i mean drywall is
really
everybody knows you're halfway to doing
drugs
and so i wish you well brother and um
you know your girlfriend got the
opportunity to have an experience
and uh i appreciate you karen for even
what i think about it
i just i would suggest that you just let
her do it and try to find ways to just
be as supportive as you can
you know let her go have an experience
now you hope she doesn't really get real
indigenous out there
you know and she's you know out there
making you know
meets a sherpa or something like that
and they're
you know starting a little swiss family
robinson or something but that's
probably not going to happen man
people's hiking is dangerous people die
and uh you know it's hard to get erect
when everybody when people have fever
when their people are hungry and uh
altitude all of that there's a lot of
factors that are gonna really
probably keep the man off of her but i
think the biggest thing man is just to
love her and just do you would do what
you can to love her and just
yeah send her out on the wall send her
out on the wall on the way and be
supportive
you know get her a nice compass or get
her a nice uh
you know something that when she looks
for direction or thinks about direction
that she thinks about you
you know because that's gonna i think
really then you're gonna get into the
entrails of her thoughts and of her
feelings like oh man
the real direction i need in my life is
that fella right there
um but yeah it's tough because you don't
want to hold somebody back from an
opportunity but
at the same time you want to hold
somebody
and that's a real tricky biscuit man
that's air in water man that's aaron
water
um let's hear right here aaron rodgers
speaking of air
uh aaron rodgers on jeopardy
a question came in on aaron rodgers
somebody asked him
this was interesting over to our two-day
champion on the end
scott did you come up the correct
response who wanted to kick that field
goal
that is a great question should be
should be correct
but uh unfortunately for this uh this
game today that's incorrect
and you're going to lose and a man asked
him on there aaron rodgers famously
they didn't make the the super bowl
because they uh well who knows if
that's why but they they chose to kick a
figal instead of go for it
um and so a guy asked him that on
jeopardy when he was hosting jeopardy
aaron rodgers has the most punchable
face i think i've ever seen really
there's just it's just so punchable
um but yeah i think that was great man
i love it when somebody hit somebody
with the surprise with that rare element
you know you hit him with that plutonium
or that egregious bro when you shocked
the table bro and hit him with that
periodic [ __ ] uniqueness dog gang
so that's a good question who wanted to
kick that field goal who knows man
ah what else do we have man
we got a lot of uh
calls that came in let's do one right
here that came in
hey theo what's going on bro my name is
brad i'm coming to you from
gaylord michigan big bread
and that's a rare name man that's the
carbohydrate hitter baby big bread let's
hear it
um i just got two questions for you here
the first one is so i'm going to stop
i'm 22 years old and i'm going to
stop smoking weed on monday here sure
you are bread let's hear more bud
um i know you used to be addicted to
them cigarettes
so i'm just curious on what you would do
to kind of keep your mind off that
and to like not reach for one oh yeah
man stay away from that weed because
that weed is a nice
it's like a pillow but you put it's like
a it's like putting your head on a
pillow but the pillow's inside your head
i think i would probably do some fitness
too i think doing fitness it's like it's
hard to go for a jog i feel like and
then want to get stoned
i feel like if you activate the other
side of
you um that physical side maybe it'll uh
it'll just keep your pump up and you'll
feel so good off them endorphins you
won't want to get
playing it out but those are my thoughts
you know i don't know
you might want to smoke weed forever
also
you might want to do it and just not
tell your friends you might want to
you know you could try dmt you know that
could help you quit
that's what it got me to quit cigarettes
you know when i still
actually i don't man i it took the real
desire to have that
that hit out of me
because that's the thing about smoking
weed i want us i want to suck on that
thing bro
i want to suck on that grassy grassy
knob
daddy you know what i'm saying that
giant
i want to [ __ ] tickle my lungs with
that [ __ ] soft little field stick
baby that junk
so
i wasn't good at them johns man a lot of
brothers are better at smoking weed i
think than whites
praise god man and
you know i seen a mailman the other day
smoke or male woman i'm not sure
it was a man or woman and they were
urban you know and they was smoking a
giant
and i didn't [ __ ] say nothing you
know what i'm saying bro like
you know what i'm saying you can't you
can't say anything anymore so you just
kind of pray for him and just don't use
the postal system anymore
you know it's almost getting back to
days you just take a letter to somebody
if you need to get it to them
but uh but anyway what else you got bub
also i got me and four buddies coming to
uh
making a road trip down to nashville
tennessee
and i'm just curious if you have any
input on what we should do we're staying
right on broadway there
i don't know we don't know if we should
pull up with some cowboy boots and a
cowboy
hat just curious if you could tell me
how it's looking down there
well look it's open it's open carry as
well i think it's an open carry states
you could glock up
i think they just opened that up and um
you know it's the central east man so
it's all types of people broadway does
have a real country vibe to it
but there's all types around here
there's all types around here and it's
um you know it's a tourist destination
uh i think find some things to do that
are outside of just right in the city i
mean unless you guys are just looking to
rage
if that's the case if y'all was looking
to shed some skin bruh
and just dick out or whatever they call
it you know
or just touch titty or whatever then
you'll be fine but
if you want more than that then you'll
probably need to talk to a concierge or
look at a um
you know like a family or something and
find other stuff to do
my favorite thing to do is just drive
out to the countryside you know just
take a cruise out somewhere but
that's not always the thing you're
looking to do when you and your buddies
are just trying to get bent out
you know and try and try to make sure
everybody's straight that's the thing as
you get older and you go get wasted with
a bunch of friends it's really
you just got you know that's how you
find that's how you just make sure that
everybody's straight in the cl
so what else man i know that this story
came in right here
and this is a news story
man dies in
taco eating contest
family file suit a california man choked
and died during an amateur taco eating
contest at a minor league baseball game
the son of the man is suing the events
organizers for negligence
the president of the league declined to
give a statement
you know
there's a lot worse ways to go man
there's a lot worse ways to go than with
half a taco in you
and these days nobody wants to have any
accountability no matter what it is
you know everyone everybody wants to
hashtag taco tuesday and
you know nom nom nom nom
but they can't back it up in the streets
they get out there
on them taquitos or them beef
quesadillas
and they can't back it up bye
so i think in this case you almost got
to let bygones be bygones man
unless they use that t-shirt cannon and
shot it down your boy's gullet
i mean it's highly unfortunate
you know it's first of all it's
extremely unfortunate to even have
people
know that you were at a minor league
baseball game
and then that you never left
because you're with the lord now and you
got taco'd out
i mean it's heartbreaking man and uh
and i feel for the family and i feel for
the fella that went down
on that uh on that entree
but i don't know if a lawsuit helps
it's just gonna you know it's gonna
[ __ ] the team the team will be done
so
maybe see if you could sue to have to
change the name
you know sue to see if you could change
the name to something in memoriam of
your son
that might be kind of nice uh
at least that way there's going to be a
piece of him still alive you know
in a special way that will because other
people are going to go to the games and
find joy
but but i'm sorry man r.i.p bro praise
god bro
so oh
man i'm tired today it's been a long
couple of uh
you know i was out of town for like a
week
went to l.a then went to easter and um
and it's good man you know it's good man
uh what else we got
a a video that came in right here
let's take a peek it's a young fellow
down syndrome
and you know i beat it and this
beautiful fellow right here this toddler
he's playing football
oh
beautiful man this fella for the wild
cats
and he has down syndrome and he played
for the wildcats and uh
and they let them run in for the score
you know and that kind of stuff is sweet
man it's beautiful to see it's beautiful
to see the little fella
getting out there getting into the end
zone feeling that just that
fire you know because so many people
don't get to feel like camaraderie
i do think though that somebody towards
the end of the thing should have lit him
up a little bit
you know have a brother at least a mixed
dude
fly in and just right as he crosses the
goal line crack him a little
just to really
because that's how you learn man going
through the fire
you could let anybody just run across
the track you get a good
feeling i'm sure it's uplifting
but knowing that you got laid down by a
mix dude right at the end
i think that that makes it even doper if
he shows it to his friends or
when he watches it back you know
it gives it that vit troll
so i know the fellas already got that ds
on them and i wish they you know
you know i feel like they just should
have
had a brother crack him down at the end
or
just somebody and not like hurt him
you're not trying to hurt the guy
you know he's already got his thing
going on but
you want i just feel like you want him
to feel feel the whole vibe of the game
but i don't know you know and that's
just my take on it man
and i probably shouldn't be allowed to
have takes on things but
what else do we have here man uh
let's do one or two more
and first i want to let you know also
that um
you should know that the dick pills are
good
they're good man you know your penis is
rare
you know your penis is like a
fingerprint it's the only one that looks
like your penis
you know that you know 6 out of 12
people can't even draw their picture of
their own penis decently
unbelievable but that's the times we
live in
that's where we are and and what i'm
telling you today is that blue chew
can help you out i got a batch of them
if you don't want to eat a whole whole
one just nibble a half dog
and go hard bro or go semi hard
blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients
invite as viagra and cialis their
tablets help men
achieve harder stronger erections
to combat et if you were in a war if you
were an electrocution
somebody slam your dick and at all
whatever happened to you somebody put a
trance on your dick whatever happened to
you
blue chew can help you don't like
swallowing pills no problem blue chews
still don't awful
and total awful tablets are chewable
their tablets are made in the usa
they prepare and ship direct it's
cheaper than a pharmacy
that's right blue chew
a unique online service it's an online
prescription
service no visits to the doctors no
awkward conversations
here's a special deal for our listeners
try bluetooth free
when you use our promo code theo at
checkout
just pay five dollars shipping that's
bluechew.com
promo code t-h-e-o to receive your first
month free
and we thank bluechu for sponsoring the
podcast
i've tried them i like them i like them
to get you that rum spring a dog
you know because you want to amish up
that rod fam gang
all right
here's a call that came in right here
what's up dio my name is nate i'm
from new york i'm 26 years old and i
suffer from pretty severe anxiety
okay nate anxious nate baby
that rattler dog you got that rattle in
you
yes sir let's hear more
and i know you take antidepressants and
and
you're quite open about it and i'm
really nervous to um
inquire about it i'm nervous that i'll
lose my edge i'll lose my personality
i'm uh i'm an artist and i'm nervous
that'll zap my creativity
but uh i most certainly see that it has
not exactly yours
um so i was just wondering if you could
give me any advice
i appreciate your honesty man thank you
for everything
peace out gang gang gang nathaniel and
thank you
thank you for reaching out man and just
checking in with us and and for sharing
that you got your own anxiety meds
i mean they're pushing meds dude if you
look at commercials
one out of three commercials is for meds
there's only like nine companies anymore
and one out of three commercials is for
meds man it's intense out there and so
you
everybody's on something or hell the
other day i unzipped my pants my penis
was taking a pill i didn't
i didn't have anything to do with it
everything's pilling out
you know you'll find a dang pill in yeah
you know it's like that people's peeled
out
everybody's on something but um
you know the anti-anxiety me yeah i've
taken them all man
zoloft but i would call zoloft
no loft because i couldn't get that
erect
you know they really have i was really
sponged out in that wing baby you know
it
so the hard part is keeping your penis
full
because the crazy part is your brain i
feel like will get happier
on the anti-anxiety meds your brain will
get better off
you just don't care about things as much
you see a squirrel gets shot or
something
you do you you feel bad but you don't
feel bad you just
know you feel bad
something sad happens you you get
sad but you don't get that sad you just
kind of know
that you feel sad
so it kind of you know like when you
went bowling as a child
and they had them bumper bowlings on
it's like that
but for feelings just puts the bumpers
on man
and sometimes i want the bumpers off i
want the full throttle
i want that dirty monty you know
i want that nast and ass damn i want all
the feelings
so that's the trade-off you don't get
the highs and you don't get the lows you
get a whole lot of harsh
mediums good and bad
so sometimes i wish i could quit and now
i can't quit
i quit for a few days and i spiral a
little
and i don't even know if it's placebo or
if it's real
but i quit for a few days and i then i
get real scared
one bad thing happens and i think you
know i start feeling some type of way
and
then i feel like everything's going to
be bad and i have to get right back on
it
and it's crazy to me that a you know
something that i went in for 20 years
ago
they gave me this pill and i'm still
taking it that's
that's wild it feels not right like if
you
broke your arm and they put a cast on it
20 years ago if you still had the cast
on
it seems like they'd have some way to
get you off the cast
and that's the thing about it it's more
like getting
i don't know it's like an eternal thing
but don't feel bad about it a lot of
people are on it
i would just kind of monitor how you are
on it
and then make an educated guess for
yourself
you know these are unique times and
these are metted up times
and uh just know you're not alone man
and and and people love talking about it
hell you flash a fluoxetine or a damn
um what is that other one called it's uh
wellbutrin at a bar
i mean look [ __ ] love butrin i've
seen those shirts before
so so it's possible to really find joy
even on
on the pills and everything so
um
oh man my back hurts something always
hurts jesus man
getting old your [ __ ] body [ __ ]
was hard it's hard man
and i gotta pee all the time i start to
feel like i'm just carrying pee around i
feel like a camel
more than a person like oh here's some
more p here's some p
here's some peepee
matter of fact i'm a pee before this
last uh call
all right you know i'm
lucky to have a job i gotta remember
that i've been making a lot of gratitude
lists recently and that's been
helping me keep my mind in a good spot
you know because the world is weird the
world is always gonna be weird
and really our world is better than a
lot of people have ever had it
and uh and i believe that
and um i gotta take care of
my space and my brain space you know
i be be careful where i set my brain and
where i set my attention and where i set
my
sponge
because you'll absorb man
let's take another call that came in
here man uh
here we go
hey this is jordan not in denver
colorado
hey jordan thank you for the call man
you sound like my friend uh
john who's a friend of mine that used to
work for uh
j.p picone i think they did construction
or something
i think he's still alive but not
definite let's hear more brother thank
you for calling jordan sorry
uh been a long time listening to your
podcast
i work by myself every day so i
have you in my ear most days and you
help me
get through and make me laugh and uh to
make the workday that much
easier um well thank you man i
appreciate that
you know uh you make my work day easier
by being
on the phone here and just uh chiming in
so thank you for
um for checking in man gang homework
i was just calling my uh my little
brother
a couple years younger than me he just
graduated from uh
physical therapy school and he's
supposed to get his
license and you know go start off on
that career and
uh lately you know alcohol has gotten
the better of him and
you know his addiction is is winning out
over
over that you know potentially new
exciting career and
um you know he just he had about six
weeks over
um and relapsed this past thursday
and he's just been deep in it and uh
you know you can he just he doesn't want
to live you know he wants to drink
himself to death
and be left alone to do it and uh
i don't know how to reach him man so
any advice you might have for me uh
you know i i know you know so much about
this kind of thing and
you know listen you talk to other
callers on the podcast and
so if you have anything you can give me
if you have time to
shout out to him um and just let him
know that
you know he's worthy that he's okay
i appreciate it gang bro thank you man
thank you for calling
uh you know thank you for caring about
your brother you know thank you for
putting that into the world
um
man it's hard it's hard to watch
somebody we care about struggle bro it's
hard
you know it's hard when we can't see
uh when we can't feel how much people
care
i think that's a common problem with
people that struggle
is they can't feel the care for some
reason they just can't feel it they just
don't
their antennas their and heart antennas
are not very long
and they have a short memory their heart
has a short memory
that's literally what it feels it feels
like sometimes like my heart just has
such a short memory
and i don't want it to it's not a choice
it's a defect
um but man
thank you for just reminding me of what
it's like to care about a brother
uh thank you for just sharing like you
know um
for sharing that it just hearing you you
know
just call you care about your brother
you want him to be okay
you know um
[Music]
yeah and if i had a message for him i
would just say hey man you know uh
i wish you didn't feel so bad
you know i really really wish you didn't
feel so bad
and i bet you're probably hurt in a
place that you can't even access
and i bet you want people to see how
much you hurt but you just
no matter you feel like maybe no matter
what you do it's not going to show them
and yeah i just want you to know that uh
that
that there's a possibility for things to
get better there there
there's ways for you to feel better and
i know it may not feel like that's
possible
um but but there really are
this year has been hard this life has
been hard in some ways in
in emotional ways
you know living is a hard thing to do
it's an un it's a job that you never
signed up for
it's like suddenly you're like nine
years old you're like holy [ __ ] i
work at fedex like i don't know
it's a shock a lot of times um
but i'm sorry that your brother's having
such a tough time man and i'm sorry that
you're having a tough time too
you know i've had siblings that have
struggled and uh
and i've gotten message from people who
know that i struggle and it's just it's
you know i know it's so hard for people
to watch other people have go through
a tough time and you know i wish your
brother knew how much so that we wanted
him here
because if he's deep enough to feel all
that pain bro if there's that much depth
in him
then there's that much depth in him for
joy as well
you know there's not many people in the
world that god kind of lets walk through
that
that depth of pain man
so for him to if for him if he could get
through it and to be able to then
help others dang it's like talking to
christopher columbus bro
it's like talking to that emotional
magellan you know they've been on those
high seas
it's just a lot of uh
it's almost like going outer space man
but like inside yourself you know it's
um
that discomfort
that pain and wanting to detach from it
and wanting to detach from the world
i used to think so i was like that oh
i'm gonna hurt i'm gonna do you know
you're gonna watch me
suffer world you know
because you did this to me world you're
gonna watch what i'm gonna do now
i'm not even gonna take care of myself
you know that kind of thing
and um
yes i don't know man
i've been having a tough time recently
kind of connecting with some of my own
feelings but
um but i'll hit you up man i'll i'll say
hey to you off the show and uh
and see what's going on but
we love you dog and we love your brother
and
you know it's uh we
i just commend you for taking different
avenues to try and show him that you
care
man it's so hard if if somebody really
is an alcoholic it's so hard for them to
know that people care it's just
it's just hard man
they just you know we can be in such
denial sometimes i'll be standing in
cotton
and i just won't believe it soft man
you know i just want to have such
control over everything it's just
anyway i'm kind of rambling man and i
don't mean to be separating from uh
from your call uh but
it's been a long week for me and uh
and i'll reach out to you man and say
hello but uh but thank you for calling
just even putting
your brother on our on our minds and
hearts for a minute bro
you know we need it in the world we need
to be thinking about one another
you know
because it's [ __ ] cool it feels good
man
you know somebody cares god that feels
good
when that arrow of love comes from
somebody and it goes
it somehow makes its way through that uh
kaleidoscope of [ __ ] and it just
and it man
and it's getting rarer and rare baby we
out here [ __ ] firing
in matches so gang man thank you for
calling in man
and uh be good to yourself dude
you deserve it um yeah if you have any
suggestions too for uh
for jordan right there that could um you
know
i mean i know we can you know we could
suggest 12 step which is stuff we know
it works but if you have any other
suggestions feel free to hit the hotline
i want to say happy belated birthday to
uh sean dugan
who helps out here in the central east
and he's a young fella and
you know he's always battling the dark
arts but he
he carries a strong sword and what else
man
that's it really that's it
um did i see it
you know uh you guys be good to
yourselves man take care of yourself
and um and take care of each other
you know we got this [ __ ] man i hate to
be preachy i feel like i sound so
preachy right now
my [ __ ] back hurts dog i feel like
somebody wish somebody would [ __ ]
shoot me in the back with a damn
ibuprofen gun
oh that feels so good wouldn't it feel
so good if somebody just came up on the
street
and just pop up but it was like tore it
all i'm like oh
let's go out the way that we came in man
we all need that dip we all need that
restart
we all need that man gang
just baptize me by robert randolph and
the family bank
i need redemption
i'm lost in the blood
thank you please
[Music]
what else can i see yo baby
damn got it wrong with him baby let's go
[Applause]
though
i'm a brand new man baby
[Music]
and there he is right there robert
randolph and the family band
baptize me
grateful to listen to that tune today
you guys be good to yourselves man you
deserve it
you